I had a dream last night that it was the best episode we've ever done. So I couldn't sleep the rest of the night, got in here, fired up the old machine, and I'm now waiting on these guys, and I am loose. I got a little bit of a sweat going, the hammies are pliable, flexible, and the jaw muscles are ready to really ask some tough questions and giggle at my funny little friend, Sean and Will. Guys, welcome to Smart Less. I'm sorry. I'm sorry. I'm sorry. I'm sorry. I'm sorry. I'm sorry. I'm sorry.
I'm sorry. I'm sorry. I'm sorry. I'm sorry. I'm sorry. I'm sorry. I'm sorry. I'm sorry.
I'm sorry. I'm sorry. I'm sorry. I'm sorry. I'm sorry. I'm sorry. laughed so hard as I did today when we were standing on the street. We just come out of a meeting the three of us like adults like adults and Sean Sean starts to say something and he like he's doing right now he he undoes a top of a bottle of water and he's about to take his hip and or he's going to do it and Jason slaps it out of his hand. Lans on the ground. And Lans on the ground. Just a fun, just kind of fun little hair pull. Yeah, just a little fun fun fun.
A plastic bottle, nothing broke. So I reached down to grab it, because it falls at my feet, and I handed to Sean, and as he reaches for it, I just drop it right before he can grab it. Like it's Sean. That's twice.
Twice, twice. And denied water. And as it lands on the ground, Sean reaches down to get it. And can grab it. Like it's not that twice. That's just one. That's just one. And as it lands on the ground, Sean reaches down to get it and Jason kicks it. And it goes flying. He hits a curb and goes under a park like construction truck. It explodes. It explodes. It's flying off the waters everywhere.
It's fucking funny. And I haven't laughed that hard. I failed the way it was. Because it was, it was high school all over again. It was like, it was a little bullying. Or just it, you know, it was high school all over again. It was like, it was a little bullying. You were just, you know, it was just fun. It was just, it's kind of, it was fun. Jay, did you like my cheesecake last night?
Yeah, cheese. Now I would have liked it a little firmer, Sean. A little? Yeah, it was a little too fluff. You know, it wasn't as gooey as the last one, so I feel like we're making progress. I like that last one. No, I say this as a person, I can't even boil water.
So the fact you cook anything is incredible. It's very impressive. But also, I didn't know, well, either that I've never made whipped cream in my life. I didn't know that you just pour half and half or whatever in a bowl. And whip it. And you just start this special.
You just start whipping it. I was. My mind was there. I was like, Oh, you think it's a good idea that you've now learned how easy it is to make whip. I think so. I think so. I think you don't.
I'm doing it tonight. Yeah, you missed out on a good cheesecake last night. Well, but then I found out then Sean told me that the secret ingredient that he does drive an hour and a half for. Yeah. I found out then Sean told me that the secret ingredient that he does drive an hour and a half for was a British chocolate Cadbury white chocolate bar. No, not Cadbury, it was another brand, but yeah. Another brand that we're not going to mention, I guess. We can't have you on, it's called Milky Bar.
Well, we already mentioned Cadbury, so we're kind of committed. But is that a thing? Is that normal that there's a white chocolate candy bar in most cheesecakes? Well, no, no. I just melted it to make kind of like the creamy part, it was one of many ingredients. But it's, you can all think. Sorry, you thought you tuned into Smart List. It's, it's cook-less this week. Baked-less. Yeah, yeah, I know. I was so obsessed with getting ingredients right. I drove an hour and a half to get it because they don't sell them in the United States.
And what did he do? Well, when he got there, he drove to another country. And he when he drove an hour and a half away to get this to what did he do while he was there? He's like, huh, well, look, here's a, here's a rare hamburger joint that we don't have near us. Yeah, that's why he went to portillos. To portillos.
Yeah, and he put a big burger in his face and a shake too, I bet. Yeah, I got a shake and a cake. And I got fries and a hot shake. And a shake for lunch. A cake fries and a hot dog. And then when you would be sandwiches, two beef sandwiches, one for body. And this is when you were on the mission to pick up a school bus? White chocolate. Yeah, well, I had picked up the white chocolate. Were you buying for all the kids in the school bus? No, I never get it.
So I bought like a little extra stuff and I put it in the fridge and I'll heat it up later. Good for you. Thank you. Guys, let's get started. Oh, wow, I thought we had, but. This is really exciting, guys, today. You're gonna freak out. Oh, it's your guest. Oh wow, I thought we had, but. This is really exciting guys today. You're gonna freak out.
Oh, it's your guest. It's my guest today. I'm so excited. We got my favorite red-headed firecracker here today. She's a self-proclaimed computer nerd and before becoming one of my all-time favorite full-fledged movie stars, she made people websites for free.
In fact, at 14 years old, she performed a PowerPoint presentation to title Project Hollywood. In order to convince her parents to let her drop out of high school. I moved to LA from Arizona to preserve her dreams of becoming an actress. Thankfully, that dream came true. So we could talk to her today. Her name is Emma Stone. Emma Stone. Emma Stone. Emma Stone. And Emma's a little under the weather. I'm a little under the weather.
Oh, that's so cool. I can't believe you showed up for us. Did you get into a big pile of bad co-class 9 Emma? I liked it. You know what? You've been there, right? Right, right. There's meetings for you. Yeah, listen, we're saving a seat for you.
I know, thank you. I know. I knew it home or in a hotel. We're going to hotel. We're going to hotel. It's a home. I should have been alive for my first ever. Thanks for having me. What an open. Emma's been up. I'm sorry. I'm sorry. I'm sorry. I'm sorry.
I'm sorry. I'm sorry. I'm sorry. I'm sorry. I'm sorry. I'm sorry. I'm sorry. I'm sorry.
I'm sorry. I'm sorry. I'm sorry. I'm sorry. I'm sorry. I'm sorry. I'm sorry. I'm and I was born blonde. But I was born hairless, but then I grew blonde hair. Okay. Hairless is my podcast. Sure. Give us the full.
Bravo. The, uh, yeah, I died. I read. Yeah, you were read for a while there, yes. For a long time. I was so much so that people thought it was, it was that you were Natch Red. Red Natch, but I, but I'm not red.
Natch. But wasn't a true. My mother's red Natch. Yeah. People thought it was it was that you were Nat red red that I but I'm not red match. Well, it wasn't a true. My mother's red match. Yeah, yeah, you had to be careful with that. I have a son who's a match. Ginger. I love a match. Ginger. Oh my gosh, we ever love a match.
So filthy from the very beginning. Wait, am I I. Didn't you? That's not that ginge. That's what. Hey, man. Do you mean a second? Take a nap. I've been up for days. I'm so excited you're on the show with us, Emma. Thanks for having me.
But wait, didn't you diet originally like when you moved here and you felt like you weren't getting part, or something, I feel like I read something, and then you thought maybe your talent, which you're seeping talent, that that wasn't good enough. And that's what I was telling everyone. Yes, and that's what I kept saying. Right, like, no, no, no.
That hair had got to go. But you thought you had to dye your hair, is that true? Yeah, I was, because I moved to LA when I was 15. And so all of the things that I was auditioning for at that time were kind of, you know, like rolls for 15 year old girls at that time were a lot of girls that were very, I guess what I was up for was a lot of very blonde cheer
literary kind of rolls and I didn't fit those very well. And so I thought if I dyed my hair brown, it would really set me up. Yeah, yeah, yeah, that'd go. You know what, great, Jason, when Rissie got her heart. I didn't get any parts after that either. But a couple of years later, I auditioned for Super Bad.
And I was at the camera test for that. And Judd Apatow said, well, maybe she could have red hair because the other girl in the movie, who's my best red now, Martha McEyzek, had brown hair. And so we dyed my hair red. And the rest was, you know. What was, dude, is Sean's incredible research accurate? Were you really doing websites for people?
Like, are you a computer person? I was in that kind of 90s computer format. I don't know if you guys know, Angel Fire, Geocities, that kind of world where you did, a very primitive HTML. This is not coding by any means. I would not, if you, in fact, I don't have a computer now.
They lent me this computer to be able to do this with you guys. I'm like a neolud I know. But back then, I was very into the internet and learning about building drop-down menus and things like that. I mean, primitive, like 1998. Wow, I like that.
What are you looking for? When you're out there, you're looking. What are you looking for in a drop-down menu? Now, see, that's the thing. Key, that's the thing. When you want something to step, and this keeps me up at night. Like, if you want something, if somebody's looking to step into a really elite drop down menu. Yeah.
If you're looking for a great drop down menu, you're in the market. Now, okay. It needs to be clear, clear funds. We're not using any comic sands on my drop down menu. Okay. We're hitting H any comic sands on my drop-down. That's all. Okay. We're hitting Hylvedic a heart. You now are completely, you don't have a computer at all.
I don't have a computer at all anymore. Come on. I really don't. What about an iPhone? I have an iPhone, but it's a very incredible new iPhone 15. I don't. She's all good. It looks like you want to get rid of your old one.
It is now. We're done with that. We're done with that. We're done with that. We're done with that. We're done with that. We're done with that. We're done with that.
We're done with that. We enjoyed our experience, but whole mama was our heavy rotation. Sorry about that, America. Wait, so you do, but you do, do you do email off your phone then? I do email my phone and I, you know, just, just, I bet with my thumbs. So no social media, I know nothing else. No. No, not that. Come on.
No. That's refreshing. Thanks so much. No, I was thinking the yesterday. I said to a friend of ours, I says to him, I says. He says friend? I says friend, I says. Yep. I said, you we should imagine, imagine the reset this planet
would get if we had no social media for six months globally. Yeah, people would be willing. The fucking reset would be incredible. What do you think would happen? Well, people would learn how to manage boredom, which I think is a lost talent. I know I've tried to teach my kids, like it's okay if you're bored.
That's actually another word for relaxation. Like enjoy, take a breath. Being bored is okay. Not having anything to do at a red light or an elevator is a good time to kind of like reintroduce yourself to yourself for a minute. Well, yeah, do you ever do that thing? And then you're like,
well, you look at, I've been doing a lot lately, I don't know, where I look around and I go, everybody's on their phone, every moment. If there's a down moment. And sometimes it's reflexive because people are nervous or they feel insecure. Yeah. But when you wake up in the morning,
you don't have like a loop that you like to do on a computer with every... Oh, this is good, yeah. Well, but, what's your computer loop? Well, you know, you hit the New York Times and your email and your calendar and you kind of get your shits together. I just do all that on my phone.
Okay. So I'm probably actually on my phone more than people that have a computer. But see, what I'm picturing here is that you've got no reason or excuse to get up out of the pillows. Correct. You're still in the feathers,
will you reach over, you grab your phone? Just in the foot, I'm just in a pile of feathers. Yeah, well, you sleep in a pile of feathers for real. What an angel. What an angel. I'm down with that. Well, what's like with a nice desktop, you could get out and into the living room
and join the world. Get yourself a desktop. Get it right. This is a great opportunity for a new segment I'm calling. JB, walk us through it. No, you don't want to follow my morning. All right, so Emma, which one of your rad projects are we going to talk about today? We're going to, there's so many, but I, okay, so you answer that first.
No, I don't know. Which one do you like to talk about? I want to talk about childhood. I want to talk about all these good stuff. I want to talk about it as your birthday last week. Happy birthday. That's thank you so much. Yes.
Thank you. We love the GH. Can we guess the H? Oh, this might be mean, but sure, go ahead. No you. I mean, thank you. Are we allowed to guess the age? Can we guess the age? Oh, this might be mean, but sure, go ahead. No, no, no, no. How about, I'm going to go with 24? 25. Will?
I'm going to get real. Yeah, be real. I'm not going to play so much. Will and I work together when I was, I think, 19. Yes, that's true, really? That was a long time ago. That is true. That is true. So wait, then, then, then, then, long time ago. That is true. You're going to win then.
So wait, then Sean, you go next. Okay. I was going to say late 20s. That's very cute, Sean, and sweet. True, I really don't know. Are you truly North of 30? I'm North of 30. Oh, well, she is 37.
Oh, 35. You're the closest by far. Really? Yeah, 35. I'm young. You don't look 37. I was just guessing based on what the information. Oh really? Yeah, 35. The great name. I didn't you don't look 37. Now I was just guessing based on what the information is. Okay. Well sure.
Well, okay. No, no, no, no, that's true. We did we did we did work. There was a long time ago. I know. What was the job? Do you remember? It was called the rocker. You didn't.
The rocker. Wait, the rocker. I still need to see and what was the other one I said I need to see the other day? Um, uh, hot rod. All right. Well, let's not go through my Emma go tell everybody who is wait the rocker. I still need to see and what was the other one I said I need to see the other day Rod All right, well, let's not go through my Emma go tell everybody who is in the rock nobody seen it who is in the rocker The cast is pretty hilarious. It was rain Wilson. Yeah Jason Sedacus. Yeah, you Bradley Cooper. Yeah, Fred Armason. Yeah
I need who directed this? I'm a guy named Peter Catanio who directed the full Monty. Peter Catanio. Yeah, yeah. And John Glazer. John Glazer. Oh. The great John Glazer.
Who did Hot Rod? Who directed Hot Rod? Was that, that wasn't your Moe, was it? No, it was. Yeah, gotcha. But, that cast was pretty, it was pretty wild. Yeah, we were in Toronto. We were in Toronto.
And I feel like you weren't there for that long. I was there for a couple months. I was there for a week, maybe. And what kind of part were you playing, Emma? Well, I was playing the bass in a band that was fronted by, it was sort of a school of rock adjacent, would you say, well, by, it was sort of a school of rock adjacent, what do you say, Will? Yeah, yeah, I would.
Kind of story. Willy, what are you playing? Oh, I played the lead singer of a, of a hair band. Yeah. True story. I guess that's like, you gotta take that. And Bradley was the guitarist
and from the, the bassist. No. But it was, but it was fun. But yeah, I mean, you have not, I'm trying to think, you just have not stopped working and doing awesome stuff since the moment I became aware of you. You've just been consistently just doing cool thing after cool thing, great film after great film.
It's pretty remarkable. Not a lot of people. I'm rare. Basically, you haven't done anything as shitty as the Rocker since The Rocker is what Will is saying. I've done way worse movies than The Rocker since The Rocker. Oh my God. Subjective. Well, I think.
Yeah, it's great. It is good. Let's not go too deep through the IMDB era. I want to know. I met you once very briefly. You were so kind years and years ago, blah, blah, you never remember. I think it was at SNL. But I was like, oh my God, that's Emma Stone. And then so when I did my research for today, I didn't know that your name was Emily.
I wanna know these guys. I know why it's called Emma, but I want you to tell these guys why it's called, why you changed it to Emma. And then I also wanna know about your dog bakery thing that you worked at because I have a friend who lives in Arizona, who has a company, it's a dog poop company. She picks up poop dog poop for you just call her and pick up diamond. But it was in Scottsdale. Oh, that's where I'm from. I know. That's amazing.
Well, my name was. Have you noticed like there's been less dog poop around when you go home? You know, now that you're getting shot, Sean's friends. I mean, it used to be absolutely everywhere. Hi, I'm, but her gig, her gig is just, she's just a freelance. She just goes around town and she's looking for just spare poop that's unclaimed. Sure, yeah, that's just, you call it up. If you don't want to pick up your dog poop and she, it's called poop troll. Sherry's poop. Who's compensating her?
The city? Her clients. People who don't want poop in their lawn, man. Yeah. I'm with you. Wait. So you just let your dogs kind of run free on your own lawn, like all week, and then poop control comes and picks everything up.
That's right. The gardener comes over, picks up the poop. Yeah. Like she's not blowing the leaves and stuff. There's a few bits of hope. Wow. Wow. I don't know 30 jokes in there.
I didn't know where to. Well, it's kind of I brought it up. It's such a funny job. You take a tight five and gather them and then go back to us. But wait, a dog bakery, you worked at a dog bakery when you were a teenager. Yeah, okay. I worked at dog bakery when I moved to LA when I was 15, called Three Dog Bakerie at the Farmers Market.
At the Grove? At the Grove. I used to go there. You worked there? Yes, for, well, I mean, not for long, for like maybe six months. Wow. So, wait, Johnny, this was pre-Ricky? Yeah, this was years ago, years and years ago, right?
This was when I was 20, it's 20 years ago. Yeah, that's when I had my two other dogs. I used to go there to shop for them. Do you think that we ever ran into each other then? Probably. Probably. I think the, I think word would have got it out that Will and Grace's Sean Hayes was there.
I think you're right. I think I would have told everybody. Guaranteed. You probably had to show my team. Oh my God. Okay, so we, I must not have been working those hours. We'll be right back. SmartLess is sponsored by BetterHelp.
So in my family, which includes my friends, my friends are my family, we give gifts for the holiday season, but it's becoming less about the gifts and more about the time spent with each other, which is really, really important, especially as you get older. So whether or not your family gives gifts during the holidays, you get to define how you give to yourself, right? And the holidays are a great time to do that. So whether it's by starting therapy,
going easier on yourself during the tough moments, or treating yourself to a day of complete rest, remember to give yourself some love this holiday season. I always feel better going into therapy, and if it's taught me anything it is to give back to myself, I always schedule time for myself, and I allow myself to not feel guilty if I sleep in one day or take a few moments for myself,
so I hope you feel the same. If you're thinking of starting therapy, give better help, a try. It's entirely online, designed to be convenient, flexible, and suited to your schedule. Just fill out a brief questionnaire to get matched with a licensed therapist and switch therapists any time for no additional charge. In the season of giving, give yourself what you need with BetterHelp.
Visit BetterHelp.com slash SmartLess today to get 10% off your first month. That's BetterHelpHLP.com slash SmartLess. We get support from Viori clothing. This holiday season spreads some joy with the gift of Viori. Picture this. Super comfy joggers, leggings that move with you, and cozy hoodies that make every day feel like a weekend. Or just picture me, because I'm wearing all of that right now. Viori's got the perfect blend of style and comfort for your loved ones, whether the
gym buffs are just looking good on the go. Wrap up warm with smiles and a touch of flair with Biori's active wear and athlete's shirt. It's like giving a big cozy hug wrapped in a gift box. And let's be real, who would love that? Guys, you know the great thing about doing a podcast, I can wear anything I want. Guess what I wear, Biori? Because directly after doing these ads, I'm going to go to the gym.
And I'm going to be wearing the same thing I'm in as I'm talking to you at the gym. Viori is an investment in your happiness. For our listeners, they're offering 20% off your first purchase. Get yourself some of the most comfortable and versatile clothing on the planet at Viori.com slash smartless. That's V-U-O-R-I dot com slash smartless. Not only will you receive 20% off your first purchase, but you'll also enjoy free shipping on any U.S. orders over $75 and free returns. Go to Viori.com slash smartless and discover the versatility of Viori clothing. Thank you to State Farm for supporting this episode. Think of all the amazing things in life that are expressions of just you. For instance, the song you stream over and over again,
while you're in your 13th hour of gaming at four in the morning with all the lights up, trying not to wake up your roommates, or the recommendations that you share with your friends on the top six comedy podcasts that are the best to listen to on your way to the gym and back, or even your new haircut, which may or may not be an epic bowl cut
from the 90s and hopefully is. Everything that makes you, you, makes all the difference. State Farm believes insurance should work the same way. Your plan, your coverage selections can be personalized by you, and the ability to choose the plan you want by picking the options that fit you, like choosing to bundle your home and auto policies, is what the State Farm Personal Price Plan is all about. Getting the coverage you want at an affordable price just for you.
So, are you ready to make things personal? Call or go to StateParm.com today to create your State Farm Personal Price Plan. Price is very by state, option selected by customer availability and eligibility may vary. All right, back to the show. Tell these guys why you changed your name from Emily Tama. Well, it was, originally my name was taken
at screen actor's guild. Right. When I got my card when I was 16. So it was an Emily Stone. Wow. And so I originally changed it to Riley because when you tell a 16 year old that they can just change their name. Right. You pick a cool name. And so I originally changed it to Riley because what do you tell a 16 year old that they can just change their name. Right. You pick a cool name. And so I was like, I'll be Riley.
Right number one. You could have changed it to Emma middle name Lee. Emma Lee stone. Right? That you know. I don't know if I could pull off being a three-nameer. Okay. Fuck is there any way you could call her 20 years ago? Could you call me 20 years ago really quick? Yeah, yeah, yeah, real quick. Hold on a second. We'll pause. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
And then we'll just... Then he's a real thing though, right? That is a real thing though. All people who changed their names because of... Sack, because there's already somebody... Yeah. Michael J. Fox, I think, was because there was already a Michael Fox, right? One of the great ones is isn't, I feel like Michael Keaton is Michael Douglas.
Oh, wow. Oh, really? And he changed his last name to Keaton because Michael Douglas was Michael. Wait, I just learned, I just learned Albert Brooks's real name is Albert Einstein. That's not true. No. It's weird to go. That's weird to go.
That's unbelievable. His brother is Bob Einstein, you know, Super Dave Osborne. That was Bob Einstein and that's Albert's brother. But anyway, Emily to Emma. Emily to Emma because, well, because you're trying to get to the spice girls, right? Yes. Yeah, she named Albert Einstein because that was free. That's true.
That one's free now. Not being used anymore. Wait, so you went to Emma. I went to Emma because growing up, I was a norm, I mean, still to this day, I am, but an enormous, an enormous, sorry, I'm slurring. From all of the good, I've been up the four days. You need to take a nap.
Yeah, I gotta take a nap. I was a huge spice girls fan. And there was Emma who was baby spice. No way. Crazy about her. Yeah, I love that. We had the opportunity, when I was in, you know, like second or third grade, I asked the teacher to call me Emma, but they didn't. It didn't ever stick. But then I had the chance to do
it permanently. And here I am. I love that. Have you met the spice girls since? I have. Oh, she know that. I've met the spice girls now. I think I think she does because she didn't really special tshirt that she had signed. It was like, from one Emma too, another kind of thing. It was pretty cool. Did you keep it together? Or did you just keep it together at all? I did not keep it together at all.
But I will say, the night before, I met them, we were going to their concert in England when they did a reunion tour a couple of years ago in 2019. And the night before, I went to a party at somebody's house and the magician David Blaine was there. And he did a, just an astounding trick. He did this card trick and then it was this whole thing and it was an illusion, an illusion.
And he pulled up his phone and the card was reflected in a picture on someone's foot, you know, in the glasses of someone on a boat. And it was this crazy thing and I got so excited. Now this is a tale as well this time because I'm about to tell you a story from yesterday as well. I got so excited that I ran. I was like, I can't stand it
because I'm such a big fan of magic and I couldn't stand it because I'm such a big fan of magic. And I couldn't stand it and I ran. And I was wearing these, these heel boots. And I slipped on the wood floor this is the night before the Spice Girls concert. Slipped, my arm went back out behind me. And I broke my fucking shoulder. When was this? 2019, the summer of 2019.
So the next day I was supposed to go to the Spice Girls concert. And I was like, there is no way on Earth I'm missing this. So we got in England, one of these things from boots, the drugstore, this little sling. And I hadn't even gotten an X-ray yet. And I went and I was in so much pain that actually meeting the Spice Girls under those circumstances
was probably better so I couldn't do that in front of them instead. And you're excited. And you're excited. And you're excited. And you're so tempered by the pain. It was so tempered by the pain that I was like, it's amazing to meet you guys. Oh my god.
Like it was so brutal. It was broken in two places. And then yesterday, I have bone density issues. That's clear because I broke my toe yesterday. No. I did. I broke my toe yesterday. No. I did. Are you kidding me? Doing what?
Getting out of the shower. Yeah. Well, you shouldn't be lying down in the shower. What do you mean, getting out of it? I know. Are you accidentally stopped in on time? I slammed it into something and now it's completely black and blue and all messed up.
It's like I sing it all day. Anyway. And you can show it up for us today. God bless you. Yeah, I heard you know the castle. It's a dream sing it all day. Anyway. And you're sick and you showed up for us today. God bless you. Yeah, I heard you're not canceled. It's a dream. This is incredible.
Are you kidding? I'm sitting on a computer with headphones. This is a love book. Half of one of those excuses would have made me cancel this thing. God, I was just thinking. I would give. I was so excited for this. I would give anything for improved bone density.
Yeah. Sorry, just sidebar. Sidebar. We need to take, what is it, boniva or something? Yeah, boniva. There's some pill to help our bone density. But I've got seven bones. Before I was 30, I broke seven bones. Am I? Isn't that crazy? So then you seriously looked into this. You seriously do have a lot of issues. Yeah, I have. There's an endocrinologist was like, we got to talk about, like something's up with you. Right.
And did he come up with anything? Just that I need to take a lot of vitamin D and calcium and do apparently weight bearing exercises, like heavy lifting is what creates more bone density. Well, you could just drink milk and eat, like dumplings from Chinchin, like Sean. Jesus. He has a glass of milk four times a day. No, I have a glass of milk with dinner every night.
No, you don't. I really do. You should see. Why not? It's good for you. That's crazy. It's good for you. It's fine.
We used to sit at dinner drinking a glass of milk. Yeah, that's not a week ago. I just, I just stop. Are you just doing it to be adorable? Are you really enjoy it? No, he's just what he does. No, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I thought I saw the week ago. So I just, I just stop. Are you just doing it to be adorable? Or you really enjoy it? No, he's, this is what he does. No, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I,. So listen, I wanted to see some other reasons around medical stuff. I wish this was just a gallon of milk.
I know, I know, I know. You're so fast. But is it true because you have one of those cool like million billion dollar voices too? Is it true that you first of all didn't know you had asthma until you had an asthma attack while filming EZA, which I read?
And the other thing is, did you really have a condition when you were a baby because you cried too much? Call it, made your voice. Is that true? Yeah. Because you were colloquy that gave you a rest, people. Like extremely colloquy for five months.
What's colloquy? Can you imagine now having a kid, I cannot imagine having a colloquy baby to that extent. Five, five. What does that mean, colicky? Colicky is apparently a condition where your stomach is killing you. Like there's, you're in a lot of pain. I am.
Everything I can talk about is just my medical. No, I know. It's fascinating. But here's what I think it is. It is the intestines or part of the GI tract that is still developing and unkinking itself and there is a kick in the nose. It still needs to grow to release itself and it takes a couple of weeks and the babies are miserable.
Yeah. So it was like if I was awake, I was screaming myself horse every day and I think it was very, very traumatizing for my parents. I see. You know what's good for bone densities, though, some of those the astronauts, you know that thing, the power plate thing, the vibrates, that's supposed to be good for bone density. Oh, thanks. Isn't that kind of a fifties thing to a little belt around you that she's wearing? I read it once over a glass of milk. I was straight. I want to know, let's get to the career stuff because it's really interesting. Okay, great. How would you hang on?
How would you, baby? Let's just do a quick, how would you, baby? Two and a half. Ah, sweet boy girl. Girl. Girl, sweet. I didn't know that. That's so fantastic.
Congratulations. Thank you so much. Thank you. With your husband who you met at SNL, did you meet him at SNL? True. Dave McCarrie. Yeah.
And is he, what does he do with SNL? He you meet him at SNL? Did you meet him at SNL? Did you meet Dave McCarrie? Yeah. And is he, what does he do with SNL? He was a writer-director there for about five years. Oh, nice. Doing digital shorts. And you met him there? I met him there, yeah.
But we had a bunch of mutual friends, so, yeah. So great, I love that. I feel like I was there that week too, although you've probably hosted a few times. I remember being there once when you were hosting, and was like, oh, she's so much better. I hold on. I'm gonna host on December 2nd. I get teched by five timers jacket. Oh, I'm so excited. I can't even stand it. I'm like, I'm freaking out. You're so good at it. That's really, really cool. Wait, so Emma, you and Dave married in
the pandemic. And was that just because it was planned that way and you just kept it or you're like, you know what, let's just do this now. You were waiting for a pandemic. Were you, did you guys say you wanted to get married, but let's wait for a pandemic, did I? We're just trying to fad a little bit on this invite list. Yeah. You know, the week that I got married, I did open a refrigerator and the handle broke off and I got a plug. Oh my god. Oh my god. You need a hell of it. And that's where it stops. You know, I do need a refrigerator and the handle broke off and I got a plug. Oh my God. Oh my God. Oh my God.
You need a helmet. You know, I do need a helmet. Oh my God. I need a helmet and extensive wear. You got this new show with Nathan Field, or I want to skip ahead. I know she's your guest. Oh, yeah. That looks really...
I know she's your guest, but I'll take this one. But I'll say, it looks really fun. First of all, he's great and not just because he's Canadian, he's super funny. You're super funny. And when I first saw the ad for it, I was like, these motherfuckers, and then they got one of those safties in there. Yeah, that's true. Put a wig on him.
Then the three took the boom out of his hand and said, go, this is like a fucking, this is like a fucking talent explosion happening in one thing. I'm so goddamn excited for this thing. I mean, I'm so excited for this. It's a wild ride. Now, well, tell us about how did that come to you to your orbit? Nathan, so Nathan and I have known each other through Dave
and Dave's best friend Kyle Mooney have been with friends. I love how many years. And they've been best friends since they were nine years old. So yeah, and so Nathan, uh, new David and Kyle well, and I got to know Nathan, uh, for a couple years.
And then I think in 2020, 2019, maybe, uh, Nathan called me and said that he and Benny Safdie had come up with this kind of loose idea for a show based on something that Nathan had really experienced where someone had said that they cursed him in a moment. And he was like, this probably isn't true, but he found that it haunted him. Sure. And they started coming up with this sort of premise of what would happen if you're kind of going about your life and they had this idea for this couple who is trying to create their own HGTV show.
But early on, the husband, a little girl says, I curse you. And if that hangs over the premise of this whole show and how that evolves and kind of makes them go crazy, whether it's real or not. And it just sort of spiraled out from there and became this very intense show. It's really, it is a comedy, but it's kind of not a comedy. Kind of dark. Yeah. Yeah. It's very, yeah, there's a lot going on there. So it was, you know, it was a blast.
And we were in New Mexico for like half of last year shooting that. And say the title again? The curse. Yeah, the curse. I see posters for it everyone. And say the title one more time. And what is it over the third time?
I'm so the curse. I want to talk about poor things too, which is a movie that you have come in. The way you're the most man. I am. I'm going to go see it this week. You are? Yeah.
I can't wait. Where are you going to see it? I'm seeing it. It's one of the screen, because I'm going, I'm going to be at those. Yeah. I'll see you there. I just got a text for it.
Yeah. Oh, great. Was it me texting you to come with those? I was here. Do you go by Emma Stone? No. I'll see you there. I just got a text for it. Yeah. Oh, great. Was it me texting you to come with us? I was here. Where do you go by Emma Stone? Oh, shit. It is.
Yeah. This is the second project with Yorgos. Yes. It was technically the third because we made a short film at the beginning of 2020. And then so, but it was, it was. Yeah, it was, yeah. It was a second full one.
He's so brilliant. Amazing. We made another one in the meantime. We made another really new Orleans last year. No, really? We did with with with Willem. With Willem. Yeah, Willem's the poor things.
Yeah, yeah, we're doing two together. And so for my, for my sister, Tracy, Yara Gostid, the favorite, the lobster, just a bunch of great kill sacred deer. It's a dog too, so which is... Yeah, it's a poor thing. So did you develop it? Did you find it like you're just getting off for like how did that go?
So Yorgos and I did the favorite in 2017 and right as we were wrapping up the favorite. He told me about this book that he and Tony McNamara, who was the writer of the favorite, had optioned and they were working on adapting. And he just told me the premise of it, and I was like, I beg of you, I have to do this with you. And so for the next few years, we worked on things and started kind of putting it all together. And any ask me to be a producer
on it, which was amazing. And so we kind of like assembled this team and then at the end of 2021, why do I keep saying all the dates? Yeah, I don't know. Because you're like, well, you have incredible recall on dates. I do everything by date. So really? Month and year, yeah.
You too. Everybody's birthdays. Do you forget a birthday? Can you forget a birthday once a year? I can forget a birthday, but if you? Month and year, yeah, yeah. You too. Everybody's birthdays. Do you forget a birthday? Oh, yeah. Can you forget a birthday once a year? I can forget a birthday, but if you say like, hey, like, I can say like, oh, yeah, like, it was that time of year or that year. It was this month, the March of 2023.
The March of 2023, he knows a difference between April of 21 and March of 24. But maybe I functioned similarly. Yeah, I'm busy. But anyway, so. Anyway, so we made it two years ago, and yeah, it's just, it's probably my favorite, my favorite thing I've ever gotten to do. Really? Yeah.
Wait, so with, you work all the time constantly, it seems like, which is great, and everybody can't get enough of you. Oh. So when you go from, when you go from set to set, other than your child, do you have something? How do you set it up so it's home? Or how do you set it up so it feels like, all right, I need to have at least this, this,
this in my trailer or this, this, this with me. What a fun question. I'll tell you, I'll tell you three things that always keep me company, no matter where I am. Coke? App. Sorry.
Big plate of Coke. Just the idea, you gotta get through it. I think I'm sad with the idea that I'm on Coke just because I'm on cold medicine. I'm chasing. Go with it. You know, just suffer in through this on cold medicine. She's here on a audition. I know, I have a broken foot.
I can't believe it. Broken foot? I'm near a dance. I know, I can't believe it. No, apples and peanut butter. Really? Really? Every day for a snack, I have apples and peanut butter. Every day I have a Starbucks coffee.
Doesn't matter where I am. Could be in the greatest coffee places in the world. You're up wherever. Doesn't matter. Find a Starbucks. And what's your choice? A coconut mist. Coconut mist up wherever, doesn't matter. Find a Starbucks. And what's your choice? A coconut misto.
Oh. Coconut misto. No, a fairist misto. What is it? A coconut what? Listen, they make you say misto. But you know the Starbucks lingo where they make you say these things.
It's a venti coffee, just a regular filter coffee, a drip coffee, a large, with steamed coconut milk. Okay. And that's the meastow part? That's the meastow. That's what makes it a meastow. So that's not a latte. It's not a latte, no, because it's not espresso.
So you have apple, by the way, I have peanut butter and rice cakes, always. Everyday? Well, that's my treat. That's my snack. That's your treat? Yeah, that's my snack. I can feel like it'll be enough. Peanut butter and rice cake? Well, I love that. That's a my treat. That's my snack. That's your treat? Yeah, that's my snack. I can feel like in a minute after.
Peanut butter and rice cake? I love that. That's a healthy treat. It's not like you go and get all the twizzlers from the... Why don't you guys go with just the apple or just the rice cake? Why do you need to spread all the fatty peanut butter? Peanut butter gives you a little hit of protein and this big hit of joy. I like the peanut butter with the apples.
Enjoy. Sean explain for, not for Jason, but for Jason what joy is. It's another kind of peanut butter. Not for. No, that's giffy. Emma, like when I you were so fucking phenomenal in the favor and you won for the favorite, right? No. She did. No. No. She was fantastic though. Thank you so much. She dominated. Wait, but what was that? You wanted nomination is what I meant. Did you really not win? I can't remember.
You did win. Not for the, not for the favorite. No. What, which one did you win for? Lollol. Oh, that's right. Lollol. So I'm not going to be too.
You're so good. I'm not going to be too. You're so good. I'm not going to be too. I'm not going to be too. I'm not going to be too. I'm not going to be too. I'm not going to be too. I'm not going to be too. I'm not going to be too. I'm not going to be too. God, you're so pretty good. It's a totally embarrassing thing to have to sit here and say. No. Well, I've heard that one.
No, I want to know. I asked. I want to know everything. But wait, the favorite was yours too. My mom says I'm always a winner. Yeah, and always her favorite. Yeah, exactly. Exactly.
But was that because when I was seeing that movie, when I watched that movie, I was like, oh my God, this just looks like a colossal amount of work that movie, the favorite. Like, it just looks so grand and so massive. And then- That just gives a lot of it was in that fish I lens. That's what makes it look so grand. All right.
You know what I mean? That's a little trick of the trade. That was in England, yes. That was in England. And Lala Land was here in Los Angeles. In LA, yes. The favorite, favorite. It'sala Land was here in Los Angeles. In LA, yes. A favorite, favorite. Such a good movie.
I just wanted to go. Apart from the work that these guys were so tired, but I, that movie was so good. I must tell you. No. We'll be right back. Smart List fans, listen up. Have you heard you can listen to episodes of this very show, Add Free, and one week early on Amazon Music with your Prime Membership?
That's right, all your favorite smart list episodes can be heard on Amazon Music, Add Free, and you'll always be the first one to catch our new episodes so you can brag to your friends. But that's not all, you can listen to your other favorite shows like, I don't know, Bad Dates and Just Jack and Will, Early and Add Free too. They also have favorites like the daily, pardon my take and up first, all without any ads. You know what this means?
Uninterrupted listening, so no more cliff hangers. Amazon Music offers the most ad-free top podcasts, so we know they definitely have something for you. And it's already included in your prime membership. To listen now, all you need to do is go to Amazon.com, slash smartless. That's Amazon.com slash smartless, or download the Amazon Music app.
It's just that easy. This episode has brought to you in part by Rocket Money. Did you know over 80% of people have subscriptions they've forgotten about? It's too easy to subscribe to a free trial of something and then completely forget about it once you stop using it right as the monthly charges start rolling in. That's why Rocket Money is here. Rocket Money is a personal finance app that finds and cancels your unwanted subscriptions, monitors your spending, and helps you lower your bills all in one place.
With Rocket Money you can easily cancel the ones you don't want with just the press of a button. No more long hold times or annoying emails with customer service, Rocket Money does all the work for you. Rocket Money can even negotiate to lower your bills view by up to 20%. All you have to do is take a picture of your bill and Rocket Money takes care of the rest. Rocket Money also lets you monitor all your expenses in one place. Recommends custom budgets based on your past spending, and they'll even send you notifications
when you reach your spending limits. Isn't that cool? With over 5 million users and counting, RocketMoney has helped save its customers in average of $720 a year, and $1 billion in total savings so far. Stop wasting money on things you don't use. Cancel your unwanted subscriptions,
and manage your money the easy way by going to rocketmoney.com slash smartless. That's rocketmoney.com slash smartless, rocketmoney.com slash smartless. That's rocketmoney.com slash smartless, rocketmoney.com slash smartless. This episode is brought to you in part by Macy's. If you're feeling the holiday time crunch get all the gift in-spot using Macy's gift finder. Navigate through the holiday hustle with ease
using their helpful search options like Shop by Price. You can shop gifts by budget, whether it's $25, $50 or Lux. Shop by gift lists. Discover curated unique lists for all the personalities in your life. Is your loved one a spa day enthusiast and ad bent calendar fan? A big sports fan, Macy says, God, you covered. You can even find curated gift lists from your fabed influencers. Shop by category. Explore top picks and beauty fragrances, jewelry and watches, handbags and accessories, and more. And that's not all.
You'll find packaged and ready to give gifts, top rated customer favorites, secret Santa inspiration, and the light, full stocking stuffers. So why stress? Head to macy's.com slash gift finder and uncover the perfect presence for everyone on your list. This holiday season
make it memorable with Macy's. And now back to the show. Was that one of the hardest things you've ever done that, but what's the hardest one you've ever done? Oh God. Physically, emotionally, both whatever. Law and the land had a bunch of stuff in there. Oh, yeah. You're learning a thing. The hardest thing I've ever done was on stage. Yeah. By far.
Sean loves stage stories. I do, you know I do. Well, I've only done one professional stage show. What went wrong? Like 10 years ago. Oh, you want to, what went wrong, Sean? I want to, like, a bad theater story. Well, but here's, I did Cabaret.
And I only did it for three and a half months, which is so short by stage terms. But enough. I thought, I truly going into it. I was so beyond excited. It was probably the greatest experience of my life for the same reason. And I was like, oh, you just do it at night.
And then you do two shows a day on Wednesday, and you do two on Saturdays. And then you do two shows a day on Wednesday, and you do two on Saturday, and it's just, and then you're home, and you're just, your entire life is eaten. And it is so hard, you have to live like a monk. Like, there's nothing, at least I did, because I lose my voice and I just sing, and it was like, I've never experienced
something that, that physically, taxing as an actor. It was, it was unreal. I'm sure. taxing as an actor. Yeah, I'm sure I'm sure. And when you when you put to do anything go massively wrong, do you have like any kind of night where you just like, oh, shit, my voice nothing came out when I say. Oh, oh, yeah, I mean, I would have to take steroids multiple times. Like, no, yeah, no heart attacks in the house.
Thank God, but that's there are a lot of those stories. But that no, I just to in the house. Thank God, but that's there are a lot of those stories, but no I Just to add to my you know things that are wrong with me. I'm extremely blind blind blind is about okay and I wear a context for that and They both popped out of my eyes while I was singing maybe this time And there's and it cuts a really been reaching for a note It cuts. Yeah, I'm always reaching for those notes as I'm not a singer per se and the and the lights went dark And you have to you know go off in the in the blackout and I couldn't see a
Thing in the world and I just went like slammed it. It was terrible. That getting off stage, not being able to see it all is. That's terrifying. And then couldn't find the contacts, right? They were on the floor. Couldn't find it. But I know I always bring spares. I have to travel with spares.
Yeah. It's very important. It's very important. It's very important. It's very important. It's very important. It's very important. It's very important. It's very important.
It's very important. It's very important. It's very important. It's very important. It's very important. It's very important. It's very important. It's very important. Yeah, all of it gives me so much anxiety. But when you... I always had a fear shot of getting hiccups on stage. Yeah, and that too. Oh my God, that's a great fear. Have you had hiccups on stage? No, but I had one thing where I had allergies
and I could feel the post nasal dripping the back. And it was right before I had a sing, what do you get when you fall in love? You know, with the Christmas sun. Yeah, and I was literally like, Oh no. Like forever. Oh, God.
It was the worst panic tears because I couldn't cough, but I had to act like I was everything. It's still, I have a million. It's just, okay, I'm about to tell you guys something that I think that you're not gonna enjoy. I know Jason's not gonna enjoy this. Oh no.
What do you do when you get, I'm gonna ask you guys, I'm gonna go around to the panel here. What do you guys do when you get the hiccups? Do you have like a sure fire? I don't have one. I have a cure. I have a cure.
I have a cure, but people tell me that I'm wrong, but if not if you do it, right, okay? Here's the thing. Yeah, you don't scream at people. This is the saw. Pull your arm up above your head. Just take one arm. Put it up above your head.
Well, just because I'm right handed, so if you're left handed, you can do it. Drivers don't do this. You take your, don't do it if you're driving. Now, take water, and I'm talking like tiny sips, you go, swallow, swallow, swallow, swallow, as you lower your arm slowly. Well, nothing's gonna happen,
because look at all of this. Is that a mistake? We're all chewing it. Why would you practice it? Listeners, we're all doing it. We're practicing. I'm telling you, it is 100% of the time. I feel incredible.
If you do it correctly. I feel amazing. What do you guys do? You're Sean or J. I, I, I, nothing. I, I, I wish I had something. I don't think. I think a deep breath.
And, and I kind of let it feel it kind of go away and then I take water while I'm holding my breath. It seems to work. I've never told anybody this. This is absolutely true, and I can't believe I'm telling it. I'm ready. Anytime I get the hiccups,
and I remember one time vividly, years ago our buddy Edgar Wright we did this thing called Don't, it was like a fake movie trailer between, there's a double bill, like a Robert Rodriguez film, whatever, and he made this fake trailer and I did the voice for it anyway. I remember going to record the trailer voice
because I'd do it. Don't even breathe, don't even blah, blah, blah, blah. I did this whole thing, right? I was in the West Village at this recording place. And doing the thing and I had a soda, I think, and I got the hiccups because I was taking in so much air. And I was like, what the fuck? This is where I learned it.
And I was like, just give me a second, I just got to, because I'm like, hiccuping on, you know, trying to record. And I go into the bathroom. Uh-oh. And I stick my finger down my throat, and I make myself gag and throw up a little bit. Yeah. Yeah. Gone. I get it. I came back out and I finished and that's what I do every time when I get
the hiccups now I go, excuse me. I get it. That is just. We just got it. There's a better way, Will. I don't know. It works. Do you do you fully throw up or do you gag? It depends on where I'm at. You know. I hate hiccups. I will make myself. Wait, but this was, were you just gambling that this would work? Or is this something you'd kind of read about? I was just gambling. I had no idea. And I just did it. Wow, that is.
Huh. I did not know that you have a tattoo on your arm or your wrist or somewhere. My wrist. I want to see. Very, very, very poorly done tattoo. Look at this. Now this was supposed to be, I just want you to understand. This was based off of the drawing
that was drawn with a pencil, okay. It looks like bird feet. Does that look like a pencil? Is it a cactus? It's bird feet and it bleeds out more and more every single year. I got a 13 years ago and it just keeps spreading. In 20 years, this is just going to be.
What kind of half-assed tag do artists? Were you in a French prison or something? I went into just kind of a random tattoo place on 14th Street and I was, yes. Why didn't you consult with the sleeveless one? He could have hooked you up with a great tattoo artist. And now I've gone to, to good tattoo artist and said, can I get this lasered off and read down?
And they were like, your skin is so thin there that it's probably just gonna look like your burn, like it might be worse. Oh really? So wait, so I don't know what to do. And your mom got the same one. My mom, my dad, my brother, I mean, the story behind it is so special,
but it was like, and theirs all look great, by the way. Because they all went to better tattoo people. And I'm the one who's covered up for work every day. And it's like raised up. It's really. Don't you hang out with Thoreau just a little bit? I know Thoreau. Yeah, so he could have hooked you up with somebody with maybe a better needle.
I didn't know him then. Yeah, yeah. could have hook you up with somebody with maybe a better. I didn't know him then. Yeah, yeah, this was 2010. I love that your whole family has it. And he thoughts on Justin. This was October of 2010, Will, you remember? I love that. I love that. By the way, I wasn't going to say it before, but you know, when we shot the rocker, it was
June of 2007. Okay. I know. I know, you know, I know you know, um, uh, that is, yeah, Jason brought up a good point. Any thoughts on Thoreau. And by the way, this is a safe, safe place. Anything hurtful that you can think of. Another assignment we're introducing. Well, you know, he, he suffers from eczema. There we go. Does he really? That's why it doesn't wear sleeves because he's proud. He wants to show it. That's like a man in a car. He's like a man in a car. He's like a man in a car. He's like a man in a car.
He's like a man in a car. He's like a man in a car. He's like a man in a car. He's like a man in a car. He's like a man in a car. He's like a man in a car. He's like a man in a car. He's like a man in a car.
He's like a man in a car. He's like a man in a car. He's like a man in a car. He's like a man in a car. He's like a man in a car. He's like a man in a car. He's like a man in a car. He's one. Someone take it off. He did. He did. He did. He did like an hour late. I guess he got an alert or something. Yeah, Kimmel knows how to like break into someone's Wikipedia page.
He put it there. The wrong person to know how to do it too. Yeah, I love that. Will you guys put something on my Wikipedia page? Don't put that one. Put something different. No, yeah, we'll put you in a frame. We're going to put cries when Justin threw orgasms. Please, please don't put that. It would be funny to see a long life. It would be funny though.
Can I ask you about early, early, because you have a brother, right? I have a younger brother. You close with your brother? You vary, yeah. Oh, that is in the business. This is the two of us. No, no, he works in like a tech company. And growing up, was he interested or no?
He was less like, I don't know. I don't know. I don't know. I don't know. I don't know. I don't know. I don't know. I don't know.
I don't know. I don't know. I don't know. I don't know. I don't know. Hello, is it your brother? Very, yeah. Oh, that is he in the business. This is the two of us. No, no, he works in like a tech company. And growing up, was he interested or no? He was like, you do that, I'm gonna go over here. Not at all, he played football. Yeah, where was home, where did you grow up? Scotty, Arizona. Where the poop, with the poop. Remember earlier, there was the same conversation.
Huh? Yeah, how long have you been talking to him? Remember from before, it was like 20. What did you say? What did you say? And good thoughts, good feelings about Arizona. Do you miss it out there? You still have family out there?
Yeah, I still have family out there. The thing about Arizona is it's so hot. It's so oppressively hot. Yeah. It's difficult to, you need to be built for that kind of heat. And I'm not. It's not a fun heat. No.
It's not a fun heat at all. It's like 120 degrees daily. Yeah, that's absolutely. And we're gonna, and I want to ask you this because we're gonna end on an industry business question. I love a business deal. I love the business deal. I love the business deal. I love a biz, a biz deal. I love the biz, a biz deal.
I love the biz, a biz deal. I love the heat, I love the buzz. Yeah. Yeah. When you, you know, a lot of people who win and Oscar like you did for Lollaland, they, you were amazing, so deserved. I love that movie, I loved you in it.
Did you, a lot of people who win, sometimes it's known as the curse of death with some actors, but you first of all I should ask are you guys locked or before I give you these are you picture locked? Yeah, I'm on the land. Yeah, because you got the Oscar great, but a couple things were it me? And it's just tried a little harder. I got some, I got some notes. Yeah, I got some. I was gonna say, how did you, were you nervous? Did you have anxiety? You're like, oh my God, this is so great. I won the Oscar, but did you have, did you feel like,
I don't know, a lot of the times some actors who win Oscars, you kind of don't see them for a lot, like years and years and years, were you, did you have anxiety about like crap I won now, people are sick of me? Nope. Sean, nobody felt that way. No, not that I was.
No, but just like, what kind of a psycho? Sean, I put that out there. Why do you, okay, so now? Sean, would you tell us how you feel? No, no, no, not Tony. Wow, okay. You're walking up your chest to get the Tony. Okay.
Sean, that's my list. I know how he feels about it. I'm so proud of him. I'm still. I'm still. I came out wrong. What I meant was that you have anxiety about, like, I'm not going to work. People think, like, oh, you made it. I left.
This was a very lucky situation because I met Yorgos while we were filming La La Land and I left the day after that Oscar is to go shoot the favorite. Oh, that's great. So it was kind of amazing because the next day I went right back to work and was back in... Did you have time to renegotiate your deal
on your way to the location? Yes. So that was... I did delay my flight for a couple hours just to call. Just to call my lawyer. By the way, that was re did delay my flight for a couple hours just to call just to call my lawyer By the way, that was reopened just a salary portion new deal points that I'd love to no, but by the way, and that was a big complement How many great because you've been you've been nominated. I'm sure a million times for I think it's a million is a million Lots of great awards. Do you have do you have do you for a lot of great. I think it's a million. He's a million. Lots of great awards.
Do you have a bunch of great unused acceptance speeches? No, what? No? I bet you do. No, but you give some thoughts and respectful time and some thought to what you would say up there. You're not one of these in grades that would just, ah, if I win, I'll just go up there and wing it.
I bet you've got some fun stuff that you said, I just, my dream is to have like a book, a coffee table book of people's unused acceptance speeches. That's a great idea. That's a really good idea. That's a really good idea. Yeah. That maybe you should, maybe you should start compiling. You have to be anonymous though, wouldn't it? Well, right? The people with the screen. Yeah, because I guess it would be, but then how do you do an anonymous acceptance speech?
Everyone would know who it was, like the people that are thinking. What were you gonna say for the rocker? Yeah. If you had gotten up there for the rocker, well, who would you think first? Probably just Will. Yeah, Will.
Oh, good. Thanks for being our guest today. I don't even know. Thanks for having me. No, but you think you got nominated for, you got nominated for Lola and what you won, you got nominated for the favorite. Favorite. You got nominated for...
Talent. The Birdman? Is it the Birdman? Yeah. Yes. Oh yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. And you had to work with Galvanakis. Oh God, I know.
Oh, what a fucking... Is there a less talented guy in showbiz than Zach Alphanakis? You know, from your lips to God's ears. I know. I couldn't agree more. He was so, so sweet. That was, anyway, yeah, no, he really has this.
What are you gonna do for us tonight? And are you watching Golden Bachelor? No. What's Golden Bachelor? I love that answer. I love? No. What's Golden Bachelor? I love that answer. I love that answer. What is Golden Bachelor? It's a bachelor, but I don't need to know.
You should never know what it is, Emma Stone. This is why you are you. Because you don't know. I'm just out here breaking bones, getting sick. Not watching Golden Bachelor. Well, now I'm gonna look it up. You went through a phase. Sean went for a phrasaser as breaking bones, right?
Yeah. Early 20s, Chicago. Oh, God. Hey, Emma, cool it, all right? Okay, sorry, sorry about that. Sorry. Emma Stone, we're gonna let you go. We're gonna let you heal.
We're gonna let you get better. We're gonna make you feel better. I'm gonna send some soup over. You don't need to send anything. All right, good. It'll be okay, great. Yeah, I won't do that. I just saved myself a call to my assistant. So, thank you guys for having me.
I'm sorry I was such a, you know, what are you talking about? You're incredibly fast, Ellen. Huge, huge, huge fan. Huge fan. Very, very, very sweet. You're such a, you're a, you're a, you're a, you're a mega talent.
Yeah, mega. Yeah. True, true. You guys, Emma, Emma Stone, you guys so much. So, you're having me. Yeah. All the best.
Hey, hey, Emma, one thing, I want you to remember one thing. Yeah. And I hope you've lived by this credo. You can always say this to every any guy. If you want to be my lover, first you got to get with my friends. Will? If you want to be my lover.
Okay, got to get with my friends. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you so much. I will take that with me. Okay, I got it. You're not knowing that that was the Spice Girls Lyrics. Well, imagine one of the more painful things.
Well, imagine what I thought, because I didn't know it was a lyric. I just thought he was just saying that stupid crazy sentence. No. Like, what? I was trying to connect it. Did you just call the Spice Girls
stupid and crazy for the lyrics? Oh, well, not a lyric. If it was just as good by sentence for a podcast interview, and this is where I log off. What about when James Cameron, when James Cameron won the Academy Award for Best Director of Titanic, I had not seen the movie, but when he walks
up on stage, he says, I'm king of the world. Did you say you've never seen Titanic? At the time I had not seen it when I saw him go up on stage and say I'm king of the world. I got, oh, no, what did he just say? I've never seen it at all. Yeah. Oh my God. Because he got a lot of homework to do. Jason's Listening to want to be by this by his girls. Will you're watching Titanic and Sean just get get Ricky, you know, fix your cat. Thank you. Thank you. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Good night. Sean, you were right. Great. She didn't wash. It was sick. So nice. For a sick sick is a dog. This is worth. You know, when we do these late night records,
it's, it's, you know, the, the, the stakes are high that it, that it, that it'd be a good guest. And you know, by the way, for the record, it was a 4 p.m. record. So when you say late night, for most people, they'll have a different. Okay. But the other thing is I will say this and this is a compliment to you, JB, not even a fucking, I'm not there's no punchline. She has a great work ethic, like a lot of people I know who started young in, who were young in as actors, direct whatever. She has that same thing and you have that same thing, which is she sick. But I, in all the years years I've done stuff with you.
I've never known you to call in sick. Not fucking once. Yeah. Oh, there was plenty of times when I'd clear my day when it was three, three a.m. and I was still having fun. Oh, yeah, back. Sorry, except for when you blew your cool out when we were doing that fight scene on the rest of the government.
You thought too hard. You broke my colon. I know that's true. But but anyway, she does have that great thing. She's always just a god. She's so good. You always when you start listening off the stuff that she does and they're also different. You're like,
yeah, Mr. one actor is never sucked. Yeah, that's that's something. She's in that category. She's in that never sucked. It's I I was a John Good in that category. She's in that never sucked. It's I I was a John Goodman number one. He's the first guy I was thinking of when I think never as never sucked and she's in that category. There are a few people who fall into that category and she's one of them. Yeah, she's incredible. I didn't get to ask her about I want to talk more about La La Land about how it's got ready. Well,
next time next time next time. Honestly, nobody better. Here comes who's got it. Yeah, well, I love Birdman too, you know. Oh, you know what I also like to see by by birdie. I couldn't even do it. I couldn't even, I'm Chris, you're gonna do that.
You're fired. Oh, by by birdie. Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, That's good. I'll do. Bye, everybody. Smartness. Smartness. Smartness. Smartness. Smartness. Smartness.
Smartness is 100% organic and artisanally handcrafted by Bennett Barbaco, Michael Grant Terry, and Rob Umbjurf. Smart loss. Our next episode will be out in a week wherever you listen to podcasts, or you can listen to it right now early on Amazon Music, or early and ad-free by subscribing to Wondry Plus in Apple Podcasts or the Wondry app. Hi, it's me, the Grand Poova of Bahambad, the OG Green Grump, the Grinch. From Wondery! Tis the Grinch Holiday Talk Show is a pathetic attempt by the people of Ruvil to use my situation as a teachable moment. So, join me, the Grinch, along with Cindy Luhu.
Hello, everyone. And of course, my dog Max. Every week for this complete waste of time. Listen, as I launch a campaign against Christmas cheer, grilling celebrity guests, like chestnuts on an open fire. Now try to get my heart to grow a few sizes, but it's not gonna work, honey. Your family will love the show!
As you know, I'm famously great with kids. Follow Tiz the Grinch Holiday Talk Show on the Wondery app, or wherever you get your podcasts. You can listen to Tiz the Grinch Holiday Talk Show early and add free right now by joining Wondery Plus. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.